bonjour à tous j'espère que vous allez
bien on se retrouve aujourd'hui comme
prévu pour la vidéo faq vingt mille
abonnés j'ai sélectionné une vingtaine
de questions parmi toutes celles que
vous m'avez envoyé désolé par avance
pour ceux dont je n'ai pas retenu la
question vous aurez d'autres occasions
fera une deuxième afin qu pour les
cinquante mille abonnés en attendant
j'ai une vingtaine de questions qui
attendent une réponse donc on commence
tout de suite on perd pas tant c'est
parti d'où t'est venue l'idée du
précepteur quelle est l'histoire
derrière la création de la chaîne
quelles sont tes ambitions à long terme
pour la chaîne alors on a ici une triple
question dans la question d'où m'est
venue l'idée du précepteur alors ça j'en
ai parlé dans une des vidéos sur ma
deuxième chaîne charles robin où
j'explique que j'ai passé des années à
faire des vidéos de critiques notamment
des vidéos des analyses politiques et
j'estime à un moment donné que la
critique avait ses limites et que
c'était bien beau de dénoncer mais
c'était mieux de proposer au bout d'un
moment la critique
ça devient une sorte de fonds de
commerce on s'habitue à être toujours
dans une posture dénonciatrice
contestatrice et au bout d'un moment je
me suis là c'est parce que j'estime que
on a mieux à faire que de pointer ce qui
va pas on est plus utile lorsqu'on
propose des choses qui sont utiles utile
regroupe utile aux autres est utile à
soi même
donc c'est plutôt un changement dans mon
état d'esprit qui m'a amené à créer
cette chaîne est ce que je cherche à
faire à travers cette chaîne en fait
c'est très simple c'est donner des
outils de transmission parce que
j'estime que la chose la plus importante
qui soit finalement dans la vie c'est la
transmission ce qu'on va transmettre ce
qu'on va léguer la phrase que qui
m'anime en fait qui m'habite
lorsque je fais mes vidéos c'est de me
dire que tout ce qui restera
lorsque nous ne serons plus là c'est ce
qu'on aura transmis et je trouve
important de transmettre y compris si
certaines personnes ne comprennent pas
exactement parfois où je veux en venir
parce que je brasse des sujets très
différents et par exemple je pense à
à une vidéo en particulier la vidéo sur
l'hyper sensibilité
beaucoup de gens dans les commentaires
n'ont pas vraiment compris ma démarche
parce que il estime que la question de
la sensibilité d émotion c'est quelque
chose de très secondaire pour ne pas
dire une sorte d'outil du système et
d'outils de la domination idéologique
pour nous empêcher de comprendre les
choses de manière rationnelle
or même si je partage cette analyse
et les gens qui me suivent depuis des
années savent très bien que je suis le
premier à prôner la raison et à mettre
de côté
l'émotionnel qui nous empêche finalement
de voir les choses de manière claire et
lucide le fait est que tout le monde
n'est pas rationnel il y à des personnes
qui sont sensibles qui sont hyper
sensible et si ces personnes on veut se
faire comprendre par elle si on veut
communiquer avec elle on doit aussi
comprendre comment il fonctionne on doit
comprendre ce qu'est la sensibilité ce
que sont les émotions ne serait ce que
pour pouvoir s'en émanciper et on ne
s'émancipe à de quelque chose qu'on n'a
pas compris
avoir un regard sur quelque chose qui
nous est étranger
quelque chose qui nous est autre c'est
important
c'est important dans le cheminement
personnel c'est important dans notre
évolution et dans l'évolution de notre
compréhension du monde
on ne peut pas progresser dans sa
compréhension du monde si on reste
enfermé dans les limites de sa vision
individuelle et je trouve important que
la transmission prennent en compte les
différences de tempérament
les différences de sensibilité et c'est
ça que j'essaye de prôner et de défendre
sur ma chaîne
alors quelles sont mes ambitions à long
terme pour la chaîne ben on va pas se
mentir mon ambition c'est que la chaîne
se développe
qu'elle continue sa progression je suis
déjà
ravi extrêmement ravis que la chaîne ait
autant décoller en un peu plus d'un an à
peine puisque pour tout vous dire mon
ambition original c'était que la chaîne
atteignent les mille abonnés au bout
d'un an
5000 abonnés au bout de deux ans et
vingt mille abonnés au bout de trois ans
on en est à un peu plus d'un an et on a
déjà dépassé les 20 mille abonnés donc
j'estime que c'est une victoire et je ne
compte pas me reposer sur mes lauriers
je compte bien continuer comme ça
j'essaye progressivement d'apporter de
la qualité notamment au niveau technique
j'essaye de faire en sorte que ces
vidéos puissent être partagées au plus
grand nombre
ça ne veut pas dire que je suis pour le
règne de la quantité bien sûr ça veut
simplement dire que nous restons des
êtres humains il ya un être humain il
est toujours plus attiré par quelque
chose d'extérieur mans attractif quelque
chose de d'esthétique plutôt que quelque
chose qui va être moche et et mal
emballé je donne souvent l'exemple
si vous allez dans un magasin de
chaussures et que vous avez le choix
entre la même paire de chaussures dans
un bel emballage ou bien sorti de son
emballage avec les lacets défaits
je doute que vous preniez la paire de
chaussures qui n'est pas dans son
emballage je pense que comme tout être
humain
vous allez prendre la paire de
chaussures qui est dans son emballage un
emballage propre même si vous savez très
bien que ce que vous allez trouver à
l'intérieur de l'emballage
ce sera la même chose on doit prendre en
compte cet aspect de l'être humain qui
est qu' on est attiré par les belles
choses parce qu'ils aient formellement
beau et donc bajeux j'essaie de le
prendre en compte sans rogner sur la
qualité et sans rogner sur le fond dial
entendu on continue deuxième question
quel a été votre parcours scolaire et
professionnel jusqu'à maintenant
alors ça aussi pour le coup j'en ai
parlé dans une autre vidéo c'est ma
vidéo qui s'intitule travailler pendant
ses études pour l'interrogation où je
suis revenu sur mon parcours alors
notamment mon parcours à la fac
donc j'ai fait une femme de philosophie
à montpellier un master de philosophie
mon parcours scolaire j'ai été élève au
collège et au lycée henri iv à béziers
voilà j'ai été passionné par le français
par les mathématiques et parce que mon
époque il y avait encore le système des
filières au lycée j'ai choisi la filière
littéraire parce que je me trouvais plus
dans mon élément
dans tout ce qui était le domaine
littéraire
même si j'ai toujours adoré les
mathématiques notamment le calcul est en
terminale j'ai découvert la philosophie
et la philosophie il se trouve que
j'aimais ça avant même d'en faire
puisque la philosophie c'est l'art du
questionnement et le questionnement
c'est quelque chose qui m'a toujours
accompagné j'étais toujours très curieux
de comprendre comment fonctionnaient les
choses et notamment comment elle
fonctionnait au niveau général et au
niveau abstrait j'ai toujours eu une
sorte de réticences à m'intéresser aux
au cas isolé au cas particulier même si
les cas particuliers évidemment
nourrissent la réflexion mais j'aime
beaucoup l'abstraction et je pense que
c'est aussi pour ça que j'aime les
mathématiques parce que les
mathématiques c'est la science abstraite
par excellence
j'aime l'idée d'avoir une compréhension
globale c'est-à-dire au niveau des au
niveau des principes et au niveau des
lois c'est pas pour rien que je me
qualifie de platonicien parce que platon
insiste beaucoup sur l'importance des
principes par rapport aux objets
particuliers et c'est ça qui a motivé
mes études
le choix de mes études en philosophie
voilà kalimba pour ta réponse
najib qu'elles sont pour toi les plus
grands philosophes français et étrangers
alors c'est pas facile parce que je suis
très mauvais dans les classements dans
l'est dans les top 3 alors bon on va
quand même placé eagle en numéro 1 parce
que hegel c'est vraiment le philosophe
qui a le plus révolutionné ma conception
du monde et là encore je tiens à
préciser que hegel n'a été qu'une
occasion pour moi de comprendre
certaines choses parce que ce que j'ai
compris grâce à eagle gelé aussi compris
grâce à mon expérience grâce à ma vie
personnelle
et ce n'est pas un hasard d'ailleurs si
eagle explique justement que c'est
l'expérience et notamment l'expérience
de la conscience qui permet d'évoluer en
termes de connaissance et qui permet
d'accéder à ce qu'il appelle le royaume
de l'esprit c'est l'expérience en fait
qui détermine notre cheminement
intellectuel
j'ai toujours eu beaucoup de mal avec ce
que j'appelle les intellos c'est à dire
les personnes pour qui les idées sont
des sorte d'entité d'entités pur sacré
divine presque et qui considèrent que
tout ce qui est de l'ordre de la matière
doit finalement être être reléguée au
rang des choses basse des choses ville
platon justement n'opposait pas en
réalité le monde des idées au monde
sensible au monde de la matière il
disait que le monde sensible participer
au monde des idées au monde intelligible
et c'est très important de comprendre
cette notion de participation
l'idée que le monde qu'on expérimente le
monde matériel le monde concret ne
s'oppose pas au monde spirituel il en
est il en est le déroulement il en est
l'accomplissement dans le temps voilà je
vous laisse méditer sur cette petite
phrase parce qu'il faut que je continue
à répondre à la question
mon deuxième philosophe préféré disons
c'est spinoza alors spinoza c'est
quelqu'un là encore que j'ai rencontrés
pendant ma première année d'études de
philosophie à montpellier est ce que
j'ai beaucoup aimée dans la dans
l'éthique de spinoza inquiets sont son
ouvrage le plus fameux l'éthique de
spinoza ou d'ailleurs il est question de
tout sauf des tic au sens où l'entend là
dessus je vous renvoie aux conférences
de gilles deleuze sur sur spinoza et sur
l'éthique de spinoza parce que spinoza
pour moi résout le problème du dualisme
entre le corps et l'esprit
espinosa explique que le corps et
l'esprit sont une seule et même chose
perçue sous des angles différents et une
fois qu'on a compris ça alors c'est pas
la seule chose que dit spinoza bien sûr
mais c'est une c'est un point vraiment
majeur de sa pensée une fois qu'on a
compris ça on voit vraiment le monde
comment on comprend certaines choses et
il ya certains problèmes philosophiques
qui s'évapore littéralement troisième
philosophe
allez je vais citer je vais citer albert
camus parce qu'albert camus est souvent
considérée comme étant seulement un
écrivain ce qui n'a aucun sens puisque
il n'y a pas de hiérarchie entre la
philosophie et la littérature
la littérature est bien souvent un
prétexte à faire de la philosophie et
c'est karl marx qui disait que toute son
oeuvre était contenu dans la comédie
humaine de balzac
donc c'est dire albert camus l'étranger
un petit livre un petit roman de 200
pages qui se lit en quelques heures
qui est d'une simplicité enfantine
je parle sur le plan de la forme sur le
plan du style littéraire mais qui est
d'une richesse absolument insondable
voilà donc si vous n'avez pas encore lu
l'étranger de camus bien ruez vous sur
ce livre là pendant l'été profitez-en et
surtout prenez le temps de le méditer
prenez le temps de le digérer parce que
c'est pas un livre qu'on va lire pour
s'instruire en se disant tiens je vais
apprendre des choses à chaque ligne ou à
chaque page
c'est un livre qui vous prend qui vous
saisit tout entier et c'est souvent des
mois voire des années après que vous
commencez à comprendre certaines choses
que vous avez pu lire en vous disant
mais en fait c'est incroyable c'est
incroyable la profondeur d'un tel auteur
la profondeur de son écriture
enfin voilà albert camus pour moi reste
l'un des plus grands philosophes
français et je n'en fais absolument pas
comme certains un écrivain de seconde
zone pour pour élèves de lycée voilà
najib pour ta réponse à l'excellent
qu'on salue sur une petite question
pourquoi t'es-tu passionné pour la
philosophie qu'elle a été la ou les
causes de cette passion eh bien j'ai un
peu répondu déjà cette question c'est
c'est le questionnement c'est la
curiosité naturelle que j'ai toujours eu
depuis enfants étant enfant je pouvais
rester planté pendant des heures devant
quelque chose à l'observer et à essayer
de comprendre l'origine de ce que
j'avais devant moi et le questionnement
sur l'origine
c'est vraiment proprement le
questionnement philosophique on résume
souvent la philosophie à la question
pourquoi est ce a rejoint en fait la
question de l'origine parce que
comprendre l'origine c'est comprendre le
pourquoi et pas seulement le comment la
science répond à la question comment la
philosophie cherche à répondre à la
question pourquoi et c'est une question
qui peut être n'a pas de terme et c'est
ça qui la rend finalement aussi
passionnante et aussi eux aussi prenante
à la philosophie
je pense que c'est quelque chose dont on
n'a jamais vraiment fini de faire le
tour
on continue que penses tu des religions
dans le sens de ce qu'elles peuvent
apporter à l'être humain et inversement
alors les religions je trouve ça bien
déjà de poser la question des religions
au pluriel et pas simplement de la
religion alors faut savoir que religion
ça vient de re ligue arrêt qui signifie
relier et on peut entendre dans ce verbe
relier les hommes à dieu c'est à dire à
une transcendance à une verticalité et
au delà je dirais à un sens relier les
hommes un sens est également relié les
hommes entre eux ce que je veux dire par
là c'est que la religion on peut la
comprendre comme un système de valeurs
et donc un système social un système de
coexistence entre les individus qui
justement parce qu'il donne du sens aux
individus va donner du sens à la
communauté va donner du sens à
l'existence de la communauté et va
permettre à cette communauté de
s'unifier je ne me range pas du côté de
ceux qui réduisent la religion a
simplement un système de domination
je pense que la religion a été et est
encore utilisée est récupérée au niveau
politique pour dominer les masses bien
entendu mais ça c'est le propre de
toutes les croyances et je ne pense pas
que ce soit pertinent de réduire la
religion simplement un système de
domination
je pense que c'est un peu paresseux
comme manière de voir les choses
la religion c'est ce qui postulent
l'existence du sacré et le sacré c'est
ce qui ne doit pas être touché ce qui ne
doit pas être
et le sacré c'est quelque chose qu'on
expérimente tous dans notre vie
quotidienne
indépendamment de nos croyances
religieuses par exemple on va considérer
qu'un cimetière un cimetière c'est un
lieu sacré c'est un lieu où on ne fait
pas n'importe quoi et on parle bien de
profaner profanation d'un cimetière
lorsque par exemple on va tagué ou
casser des pierres tombales
sur le plan strictement matériel cassé
une pierre tombale
on pourrait dire mais après tout ça n'a
rien de grave qu'est ce qu'il y aurait
de graves a cassé un objet fait en roche
fait en pierre ferrand ce qu'on veut
qu'elle ait finalement le crime commis
bien le crime commis c'est qu'on sent on
s'en prend on s'attaque au sens et le
sens c'est ce dont ont investi les
choses qui n'ont pas de sens en tant que
tel qui n'ont pas de sens en elle même
voilà ce que je pouvais dire sur la
religion
personnellement je ma fille lie à aucune
religion référencés et je pense qu'on ne
doit pas confondre religion et
spiritualité même si évidemment il y a
de la spiritualité dans la religion
nouvelle question
bonsoir charles que penses tu de la
langue française est il possible de
faire une vidéo exclusivement dédié à ce
sujet alors de manière très implicite
j'ai déjà fait une vidéo sur la langue
française c'est ma vidéo sur booba alors
je sais que beaucoup de gens parmi mes
abonnés mais spectateurs des tests booba
et se demande même comment j'ai pu
consacrer une vidéo à ce rappeur en fait
ce que j'ai voulu montrer c'est que la
langue française la langue française est
un territoire est un territoire
absolument fascinant de richesse est
justement de transmission de sens le
pouvoir évocateur de la langue française
alors de la langue en général mais de la
langue française en particulier puisque
c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas remis
en question que la langue française se
caractérise par son extraordinaire
richesse même si parfois ça peut être un
handicap justement parce que on va
souvent utilisés de longues périphrase
ou de l'ong formulation verbal pour dire
des choses qu'on pourrait dire de
manière beaucoup plus simple donc ça
c'est un petit peu le défaut des
français parce qu'on est la langue de
molière et de descartes
on aime bien utiliser des mots
techniques et des mots compliqués mais
ça c'est finalement un autre problème
comme disait camus justement j'en
parlais tout à l'heure je considère la
langue française comme étant ma patrie
et comme hegel pour faire un peu de name
dropping la pensée est structurée par le
langage
il me paraît fondamental de sensibiliser
mais plus que de sensibiliser
d'inculquer indirectement l'importance
de maîtriser la langue aux plus jeunes
et aux enfants
la dévalorisation de la langue notamment
la dévalorisation de de la grammaire de
l'orthographe à un autre niveau ne me
paraît pas quelque chose qu'il fallait
encourager même si je suis d'accord pour
dire que l'orthographe n'est n'est pas
quelque chose de fondamental dans le
sens où l'orthographe
elle est arbitraire mais elle me paraît
important que ne serait ce que pour
l'étude étymologique qui permet de
remonter à l'origine des maux et donc à
leur signification primaire et ça me
paraît très important de préserver la
langue française de ce qu'on essaye de
lui faire subir actuellement question
suivante quelle est la différence entre
la pédagogie et la didactique
alors c'est une très bonne question
soufiane voilà ma réponse
la didactique c'est l'art de transformer
la connaissance en enseignements
la pédagogie c'est l'art de transmettre
l'enseignement je vais donner un exemple
on va prendre l'exemple du théorème de
pythagore pour les matheux le théorème
de pythagore avant d'être quelque chose
qui est au programme de mathématiques en
classe de quatrième
c'est d'abord une connaissance c'est à
dire qu'on a un philosophe mathématicien
grec du nom de pythagore qui nous a
transmis un théorème voilà un théorème
qui permet de définir les
caractéristiques d'un triangle rectangle
je sais très bien que pythagore n'est
sans doute pas à l'origine lui-même de
ce théorème mais il n'empêche que pour
nous occidentaux
eh bien nous nous rattachons cette
connaissance à ce philosophe lorsque
pythagore nous a formulé son théorème il
n'avait sans doute pas dans l'idée que
ce théorème soit un jour enseigné à
l'école
je veux dire par là c'est que c'est
d'abord une connaissance et la
connaissance elle n'est pas simplement
vouée à être enseignée à l'école il ya
des tas de connaissances qui ne sont pas
enseignées à l'école
c'est dommage d'ailleurs je trouve qu'il
ya énormément de connaissances notamment
en astronomie qui ne sont pas
suffisamment transmise à l'école alors
que ça fait partie des savoirs
fondamentaux
mais peu importe celui qui un jour s'est
dit on va prendre cette connaissance on
va la transformer en enseignement de
manière à ce que les enfants à l'école
puisse tout simplement bénéficié de
cette connaissance est bien celui là a
fait oeuvre de didactique maintenant la
pédagogie c'est l'ensemble des méthodes
que va utiliser un enseignant pour faire
en sorte que le théorème de pythagore
soit compris et maîtrisé par ses élèves
vous allez avoir des enseignants par
exemple qui vont tracer sur le tableau
un triangle rectangle et qui vont tracer
l'air correspondant à chacun d'eux des
côtes et ça c'est une manière de
transmettre et d'enseigner le théorème
de pythagore
il y en a d'autres qui vont donner la
formulation du théorème et qu'ils vont
dire à leurs élèves
vous apprenez ça par coeur c'est une
autre méthode et puis il y en a qui vont
demander à leurs élèves de mesurer les
côtés de faire des calculs et puis un
moment donné ils vont s'apercevoir qu'il
ya une égalité
ça c'est de la pédagogie c'est à dire
que un bon pédagogue
c'est celui qui est capable de
transmettre de manière effective un
savoir à un élève
voilà la différence entre la didactique
et la pédagogie
je m'arrête là parce que je pourrais
développer pendant assez longtemps mais
je pense que c'est suffisant et je ne
voudrais pas que cette vidéo dure trop
longtemps
voilà soussial pour ta réponse bonjour
quel est votre point de vue sur les
écoles dites alternatives montessori
freiner etc
avez vous une préférence personnelle
entre ce nouveau type de formation par
rapport à une instruction dites
traditionnelles
alors ça c'est une question assez
délicate sur laquelle je vais essayer de
ne pas dire de bêtises pourquoi ne pas
dire de bêtises tout simplement parce
que je ne connais pas ces systèmes
éducatifs dans leur fonctionnement
concret
j'en connais les théories et j'en
connais les témoignages de ce que j'en
sais de ce que j'en ai lu de ce qu'on a
rapporté je trouve qu'il y a dans ses
systèmes même s'il faut les distinguer
c'est à dire qu'on peut pas non plus les
mélanger dans une sorte de pack qui
serait éducation alternative par rapport
à l'éducation traditionnelle mais en
tout cas ce qu'il en ressort c'est un
soin une attention particulière apportée
à la curiosité naturelle de l'enfant à
son sens naturel de la curiosité qui
fait que l'enfant ne doit pas être
contraint ne doit pas être contraint par
des règles par des obligations et par
des devoirs d'ailleurs le fait que les
exercices à la maison s'appelle d2 voire
en soit je trouve ça assez significatif
de notre rapport à l'apprentissage qui
selon moi toujours passe à côté de
quelque chose
les enfants sont naturellement curieux
il pose énormément de questions et je
fais partie de ceux qui pensent que
cette curiosité
elle doit être accompagnée elle doit
être favorisée et ses systèmes
d'éducation à mon avis permettent
davantage cela que le système
d'enseignement disons traditionnels
maintenant je me méfie également de tous
les excès et parmi les excès je
pointerais l'idée qu' on l'adulte
finalement devrait se soumettre au
moindre caprice de l'enfant ce qui à mon
avis n'est pas rendre service à l'enfant
pourquoi parce que à partir du moment où
on en vit dans une société c'est à dire
dans un système régi par des normes ne
serait-ce que les lois le fait de faire
passer à l'enfant l'idée qu'il est le
seul maître qu'il est le seul roi qu'il
peut décider de tout de ce qu'il fait de
ce qu'il ne fait pas de ce qu'il veut de
ce qu'il ne veut pas ça va forcément
produire des individus qui risque d'être
inadaptée et notamment des individus qui
vont avoir une sorte de sentiment de
toute puissance
l'idée que rien ne peut leur être refusé
vraiment je pense que ça ce n'est pas
rendre service aux enfants que de les
faire grandir avec cette idée que
jamais aucune pression jamais aucune
contrainte ne ne viendra s'appliquer sur
eux voilà donc comme pour tout je pense
qu'il faut de la mesure
il faut de la modération on gagnerait
beaucoup à s'inspirer de certaines des
méthodes qu'on retrouve dans cette danse
et système d'éducation alternatif
maintenant je suis aussi un partisan de
l'enseignement traditionnel au sens où
il y à des savoirs qui selon moi doivent
être transmis de manière non négociable
en quelque sorte je parlais tout à
l'heure des mathématiques
je parle également de l'astronomie ce
sont des savoirs fondamentaux et ses
savoirs fondamentaux
on doit les posséder on doit aller
maîtrisé ne serait-ce que la langue je
parlais tout à l'heure aussi de la
langue française ne pas maîtriser la
langue aujourd'hui c'est se mettre dans
une situation d'inadaptation sociale et
ce n'est pas travailler à son à son
accomplissement personnel
as tu déjà lu des mangas que penses tu
des messages positifs valeurs véhiculées
dans ces derniers et de l'impact qu'ils
peuvent avoir sur les gens ne bougeait
pas voilà la réponse à la question elle
est là donc la haganah qu'une petite
partie parce que j'allais pas me
trimballer les quarante deux volumes je
connais dragon ball depuis 1994
je dirais dans ces eaux là et j'ai
découvert dragon ball bas à la
télévision et au club dorothée comme
tous les enfants de ma génération je
suis dans 86 et j'étais un passionné de
ce manga est a posteriori
j'estime que ça a été quelque chose d'
extrêmement précieux dans mon processus
d'individuation j'irais jusqu'à dire
c'est ça qui m'a permis de grandir sur
un certain nombre de valeurs qui me
semble fondamental
parmi ces valeurs l'entr'aide la
gratuité le courage l'honneur un
ensemble de valeurs qui ne sont plus
transmise aujourd'hui à l'école
d'ailleurs on pourrait débattre de
savoir si c'est le rôle de l'école de
transmettre ses valeurs mais peu importe
en fait derrière
derrière l'apparence de violence qu'on a
souvent entendu dénoncer dans les mangas
on peut penser d'ailleurs à la polémique
avec ségolène royal à l'époque qui a
voulu faire interdire dragon ball z à la
télévision au motif que c'était trop
violent
un bouquin c'est ségolène royale d'abats
c'est bien nul ça non elle est tout bête
faut savoir que pour un enfant la
violence représenté en dessin animé n'a
pas le caractère traumatisant que peut
avoir la violence réelle ou la violence
réaliste
en tout cas qu'on peut trouver dans
certains films et la violence d'un coup
de poing est peut-être moins forte et
moins traumatisante que la violence
psychologique on peut retrouver dans
certaines publicités et notamment dans
le matraquage publicitaire qui a qui a
des effets pervers
je pense dans la manière dont les
enfants construisent leur représentation
du monde
mais là encore c'est un c'est un autre
débat dragonball fait partie des mangues
absolument fondateur jeu d'ailleurs je
tiens à tirer mon chapeau à ce vidéaste
le chef au tac u qui a une manière de
transmettre sa passion pour ce manga que
je trouve absolument positive pour la
jeunesse et je me réjouis du fait
qu'aujourd'hui
dragon ball est une seconde vie à
travers la saga dragon ball super mes
propres neveux sont des grands fans de
dragon ball et c'est pas moi qui vais
les empêcher de regarder ce dessin animé
je suis curieux de connaître des goûts
musicaux il ya mon cher maxime si tu es
curieux de connaître mes goûts musicaux
tu vas pas être déçu parce qu'il faut
savoir que sur ma clé usb
tu peux trouver l'une à la suite de
l'autre une chanson booba et jean
sébastien bach
j'ai des goûts très éclectiques en fait
pour moi la musique est aussi
indispensable que le vin est aussi
indispensable que le rire est aussi
indispensable que
la poésie ou la philosophie c'est
l'essence même de la vie la musique et
la vie étant variés pluriel diverses
mes goûts musicaux le sont aussi je
n'associe pas les goûts musicaux à un
niveau intellectuel je peux écouter des
chansons des artistes tout en en ayant
ce petit sentiment de honte de bien les
aînés mais j'assume totalement
parce que la musique c'est là pour nous
faire vibrer c'est là pour accompagner
aussi des périodes de notre vie et des
chansons que j'ai pu entendre dans mon
enfance dans mon adolescence ou plus
tard à l'âge adulte on fait partie de ma
vie et à ce titre là ce sont des
chansons que je continue à écouter alors
je suis un grand amateur de musique
noire américaine
j'aime beaucoup le jazz j'aime beaucoup
la salle surtout donc la musique noire
américaine est quelque chose que
j'apprécie particulièrement
j'aime également beaucoup l'europe
notamment queen freddie mercury
les rolling stones oasis voilà ce que je
peux écouter en matière de rock
j'écoute aussi du rap j'ai beaucoup
écouté de rap américain
tupac guy snoop dogg là encore c'est
générationnel rap français ntm iam
je suis un très grand fan des gipsy
kings et je défie quiconque en sur un
octogone qui me dirait que les gipsy
kings
ce n'est pas de la musique et il se
trouve que j'aime aussi beaucoup les
musiques de films les bandes originales
alors je sais que c'est une réponse un
petit peu étrange parce que ben musique
de film c'est pas une catégorie musicale
c'est pas un artiste musiques de films
mais c'est vrai que souvent les musiques
de film aux onze cette intensité
dramatique qui fait que je vais les
écouter après coup j'aime beaucoup par
exemple les musiques des films de
quentin tarantino je peux les écouter en
boucle pendant des années j'ai écouté
les thèmes de
nombreux de ses films j'aime également
au niveau de la musique française
jacques brel alors brel n'est pas
français mais francophone brel c'est
pour moi la référence en matière de
musique francophone il est
il est au dessus des autres brassens
j'aime énormément de georges brassens
pour d'autres raisons là encore voilà ce
que je pouvais te dire maxime sur mes
goûts musicaux
que penses tu des concepts d'énergie et
vibrations as tu une approche
philosophique pour exprimer celà eh bien
je viens d'en parler en réalité parce
que je disais que la musique la musique
c'est fait pour nous faire vibrer et le
terme de vibrations le terme d'énergie
ce ne sont pas des termes que je
cantonne simplement au domaine
scientifique
ce sont des termes qui font partie
simplement du domaine du ressenti du
domaine de la sensibilité et qu'on peut
utiliser en philosophie si on les
limites bien à ceux à ce registre là et
à ce domaine là quand on parle de
vibrations et d'énergie pour moi ça une
réalité c'est pas quelque chose qui sort
simplement de notre esprit ça existe
réellement
on a tous eu l'occasion d'expérimenter
une ambiance pesante une énergie
négative
l'énergie sombre au contraire une
énergie lumineuse une énergie rayonnante
et c'est pas quelque chose que l'on peut
mesurer ou que l'on peut disons mettre
en évidence scientifiquement il
n'empêche que ça existe c'est pas parce
que ce n'est pas quelque chose de
quantifiable que ça n'a pas de réalité
l'énergie c'est aussi ce qu'on va être
capable de transmettre en terme de
motivation
et d'ailleurs ça me permet de compléter
la réponse à la première question je
crois qu'ils portaient sur mes ambitions
à travers la chaîne du précepteur
à travers cette chaîne j'essaye non
seulement de transmettre des concepts de
transmettre des idées de transmettre des
conceptions du monde mais également de
transmettre de l'énergie et peut-être de
transmettre des vibrations
c'est à dire de dire des choses qui
puisse à un moment donné résonner chez
les gens faire écho à certains
sentiments et la motivation elle trouve
sa source dans le sentiment elle trouve
sa source dans cette vibration dans
cette vibration
indéfinissable indicible mais qui n'en
est pas moins une source et un moteur
absolument primordial dans notre
expérience et dans nos actions de quoi
peut-on ne pas douter du doute après tu
es libre est ton parcours personnel où
en es-tu politiquement alors
politiquement j'en suis au point que
j'ai décrit tout à l'heure à savoir que
j'estime que l'engagement politique
c'est apporter quelque chose d'utile au
groupe et c'est ma seule ligne politique
en réalité je ne m' a fini à aucun parti
à aucun mouvement
je n'ai pas d'étiquette politique je
suis plutôt très critique à l'égard des
étiquettes politiques qui justement ont
pour effet de nous empêcher de penser au
delà des limites idéologiques auquel on
se soumet la ligne d'un parti la ligne
d'un mouvement
c'est ce que j'ai en horreur parce que
c'est le contraire de la pensée et c'est
le contraire de l'humain je me situe
pour le coup dans la même pensée que
simone veil cette grande philosophe qui
a écrit la note pour la suppression
générale des partis politiques qui
exprime bien justement que la politique
c'est le contraire de la pensée je
m'intéresse à la philosophie mais je
suis jeune et j'aimerais connaître ton
expérience par rapport à la manière de
bien lire un ouvrage de philosophie
par exemple à propos de la prise de
notes de la critique des arguments de
l'auteur et cetera j'ai parfois
l'impression de lire sans retenir
l'essentiel et j'aimerais que tu nous
transmettent tes conseils à ce sujet
alors mon cher altan n'ont pas la taille
ou cher altan mes conseils à ce sujet
alors je vais te donner deux conseils
qui ne sont pas des conseils universel
mais des choses qui fonctionnent pour
moi la première chose c'est quand tu lis
un passage passage d'un livre n'essaye
pas de d'avoir une compréhension
mot-à-mot et c'est plutôt d'avoir une
compréhension globale essaye de
comprendre le noyau dur de la pensée qui
est exprimé dans ce que tu es en train
de lire parce que bien souvent ce qui
rend la pensée obscures ce qui rend la
lecture difficile c'est le fait qu'on
cherche à dissocier les mots et les
phrases les unes des autres au lieu
d'être attentif et d'être sensible
au message général et parfois on
comprend beaucoup plus de choses que ce
qu'on a l'impression de comprendre
j'ajouterai d'ailleurs à ça que il faut
parfois du temps pour comprendre ce
qu'on a lu le sens n'émerge pas
forcément à la première lecture
la deuxième chose que je peux te
conseiller c'est si tu as une approche
disons plus scolaire le plus académique
c'est de faire des fiches tout
simplement est le but d'une fiche c'est
de ne retenir que l'essentiel est pour
ça ce que tu peux faire
tu peux l'envisager comme un jeu c'est
qu'à chaque fois que tu vas lire un
paragraphe ou un chapitre eh bien tu vas
formulé avec tes propres mots l'idée
principale que tu aperçu dans ce que tu
auras lui peu importe que tu te trompes
peu importe que ce ne soit pas
exactement ce que l'auteur ait voulu
dire peu importe que le mot que tu vas
utilisé n'est pas été employée par
l'auteur lui-même parce que la lecture
c'est d'abord une expérience
d'appropriation et je dis souvent que
quand on lit plusieurs fois le même
livre
en réalité on ne relie pas le même livre
parce qu'on évolue soi-même et la
compréhension qu'on va avoir des choses
va évoluer dans le temps si bien que
face à une même citation
cette citation ne va pas raisonner
justement de la même façon en toi selon
ce que tu aura vécu donc fait ce petit
exercice qui est un exercice assez
difficile mais prend le risque prend le
risque de mal comprendre prend le risque
de mal interprétés parce que c'est un
risque indispensable si tu veux tu
approprié la pensée de l'auteur que tu
lis alors donc là je vais passer le
début qui est un petit message de
remerciement et de compliments
merci beaucoup à toi cédric et j'en
arrive directement la question comment
aiguisé formellement son sens critique
j'aimerais beaucoup connaître le
cheminement du tien pour essayer de
comprendre ta manière d'analyser un
sujet alors qu'elles sont très
intéressantes sur le sens critique
pour ma part ce qui a éveillé mon sens
critique
c'est mon attachement absolument
viscéral à la cohérence logique on
parlait tout à l'heure des mathématiques
il n'y a rien qui me met plus mal à
l'aise au niveau des idées je parle au
niveau conceptuel au niveau intellectuel
que l'incohérence parce que
l'incohérence c'est ce qui invalide une
pensée
ce qui est dommage d'ailleurs parce
qu'une pensée peut être pertinente sous
certains aspects mais elle perd sa
validité dès lors qu'elle n'est plus
cohérente
comment faire pour aiguiser son sens
critique il faut aiguiser son sens
logique et aiguiser son sens logique ça
peut passer par des exercices tout
simplement de logique par des exercices
de déductions par des exercices purement
mathématique purement abstrait qui vont
faire qu'à un moment donné lorsque deux
informations vont se télescoper et vont
contenir une contradiction vont contenir
un paradoxe vont faire que ces deux
idées ne peuvent pas se marier ensemble
et bien c'est à ce moment là que ton
sens critique va pouvoir se mettre en
action
voilà ce que je te répondrais cédric la
question à deux balles comment les
étagères tiennent avec une seule équerre
et bien sache que ses étagères sont
d'une solidité absolument extrêmes et je
ne répondrai pas à cette question parce
que visiblement c'est une question qui
interroge et bien je vais vous laisser
réfléchir comment tienne mes étagères
c'est peut-être une question de physique
ou une question de logique ou une
question d'énergie
allez savoir qui es tu au delà de tous
les habillages que ton statut social
t'impose geoffrey alors là geoffrey tu
me pose une question très intime et
c'est une question à laquelle je suis
incapable de répondre
alors qu'est ce que je vais faire mais
je vais faire comme tous les les pseudo
philosophe je vais me réfugier derrière
un auteur
je vais me réfugier derrière jean paul
sartre qui disait que tout être humain
jouer un rôle et et le rôle que l'on se
donne
il est à la fois déterminé par le regard
des autres mais également par notre
jugement le jugement que nous avons de
nous mêmes en partie à cause du regard
des autres
en fait à chaque fois qu'on fait quelque
chose y compris quand on est seul on le
fait toujours de manière conditionnelle
conditionné à la conception à la
représentation que l'on a de soi même
alors l'exemple que donne jean paul
sartre dans un de ses livres
c'est un exemple tout bête hein facile à
comprendre c'est l'exemple du garçon de
café
il dit que le garçon de café le
le matin quand il quand il prend son
poste il fait son boulot et en faisant
son boulot il
il cesse d'être lui-même alors sartre ne
le dit pas du tout comme ça hein mais il
cesse d'être lui-même au sens où il va
faire des choses qu'il ne ferait pas
s'il n'avait pas cette fonction s'il
n'avait pas ce rôle et d'ailleurs si
vous prenez un garçon de café ou un
cuisinier ou un balayeur ou quoi que ce
soit cette personne n'a une fois qu'elle
est rentrée chez elle
on va pas lui demander de nous apporter
un café on va pas lui demander de nous
faire à manger on va pas lui demander de
faire le ménage à notre place tout
simplement parce que ce n'est plus son
rôle à ce moment là l'habillage dont tu
parles c'est le masque social et le
masque social
il est déterminé psychologiquement
moralement
philosophiquement même par notre
perception du regard des autres et
s'émanciper du regard des autres
c'est là la mission philosophique la
plus difficile à accomplir parce que
c'est celle qui nous impose de nous
émanciper de notre ego alors même que
notre ego c'est ce qui nous permet de
survivre si nous n'avions pas d'ego nous
ne pourrions pas survivre dans le monde
parce que le monde ait fait
d'interaction et ses interactions nous
impose de nous positionner de prendre
des décisions d'agir et de faire des
choix
on dit souvent que le but du philosophe
c'est la sagesse et la sagesse c'est
cette capacité à tout comprendre
finalement est parce qu on comprend on
accepte quand je dis qu'on accepte c'est
qu'on accepte au niveau intellectuel on
accepte au niveau de la compréhension
mais vous imaginez bien que si on
acceptait tout autour de nous sont
acceptées tout au niveau social au
niveau relationnel
on ne serait pas heureux donc
l'interaction sociale c'est à dire
finalement la vie en société nous impose
de faire des choix nous impose de nous
positionner nous impose parfois de jouer
un rôle
pour moi à paraître dans une vidéo faire
face à une caméra et parler tout seul
face à une caméra c'est quelque chose
qui n'est pas naturel c'est même quelque
chose qui est pour tout vous dire assez
étrange et réussir à s'émanciper de ce
caractère étrange réussir à se dire que
finalement peu importe peu importe les
matches qu'on va renvoyer
peu importe si on n'emploie pas
exactement le mot qu'il faut au bon
moment peu importe parce que ce qui
compte c'est la substance de ce qu'on va
communiquer et la substance de ce qu'on
va communiquer elle transcende notre
habillage elle transforme notre masque
elle transforme notre statut des livres
à conseiller j'en ai conseillé déjà tout
à l'heure l'étranger de camus et ce sera
le seul livre que je vais conseiller
parce que je n'ai pas envie d'être dans
le rôle du du conseiller en lecture
parce que les livres c'est comme la
musique et c'est comme les gens on les
rencontre au moment où on doit les
rencontrer
et si je te parle d'un livre et que je
te le conseille finalement pourquoi
est-ce que tu devrais suivre mon conseil
pourquoi est ce que ce livre là serait
plus intéressant pour toi qu'un autre
pourquoi est ce que mon avis aurait une
pertinence par rapport à toi et puis
surtout je n'ai pas lu tous les livres
donc je serai je serais bien mal bien
mal placé pour te donner un conseil de
lecture salut charles de questions que
penses tu du courant masculinistes
miktar quel est selon toi la relation
entre le corps et l'esprit
ce que je pense du courant masculinistes
milk tàu c'est qu'il est d'abord un
symptôme un symptôme de la modernité un
symptôme également de l'idéologie de la
division qui fait que au lieu de mettre
en avant la complémentarité entre les
hommes et les femmes
la complémentarité entre les sexes on va
préférer la logique de l'opposition la
logique de la confrontation
on va vouloir mettre du politique dans
le conjugue al et ça c'est tout ce que
je combats donc je comprends le
mouvement mis ko qui cherche justement à
s'émanciper
de d'une partie de cette idéologie qui
oppose les hommes et les femmes
bien que je n'en partage pas toutes les
conclusions
quel est selon toi la relation entre le
corps et l'esprit j'en ai parlé tout à
l'heure avec spinoza le corps et
l'esprit sont deux choses
indissociables comme l'a dit frédéric
delavier dans l'entretien qu'on a
réalisé ensemble
le corps ne peut pas se mouvoir sans
l'esprit et on ne peut pas penser sans
notre corps donc pour le coup on a bien
une relation ici de complémentarité et
je prône cette complémentarité parce que
la vie de l'esprit doit s'accompagner de
l'avis du corps et la pensée ne doit pas
être relégués à quelque chose d'austère
voire de morbide et bien c'était la
dernière question je vous remercie
d'avoir suivi cette faq j'espère que ça
vous aura intéressé
dans tous les cas n'hésitez pas à faire
part de vos réactions dans les
commentaires
pensez à vous abonner à la page facebook
merci du fond du coeur à toutes les
personnes qui me soutiennent sur tipi je
vous souhaite d'excellentes vacances
estivales
on se retrouve à la rentrée et d'ici là
profitez vivait vibrer et soyez sages
[Musique]